i would just love to start with like
more of like your big picture of where
we are in the markets and maybe your
outlook ahead
yeah absolutely so uh you know for those
who've been paying attention to the show
it's pretty uh pretty straightforward uh
so i'll summarize everything at 42 macro
we believe that if you use enough data
use enough math have enough of a
repeatable process you can sort of
harness these sort of big macro cycles
that tend to drive dispersion within and
across asset markets and obviously take
advantage of that from a portfolio
perspective to sort of you know we
consider there to be four big cycles is
the liquidity cycle so as you know if
you think about the fed balance sheet or
interest rates is that getting more
positive or favorable for asset markets
or less favorable clearly we're in the
liquidity cycle downturn our views as
we're close to let's call it 8-5 or 6 on
that um you know for those of you who
are not americans uh any baseball is
played in nine innings so you know
probably let's call it two-thirds the
way done in terms of liquidity cycle
downturn um as it relates to the growth
cycle which is another important cycle
we're probably in ending four or five in
the growth cycle downturn it's set to uh
significantly uh deepen uh in the coming
months um at least according to our
forecast uh we're probably in extra
innings in the inflation cycle upturn
as evidenced by the most recent uh pce
headline pc and headline cpi or cpi
reports that we've gotten in recent
weeks and then lastly i think we're
probably close to any one or two of the
profits cycle downturn what i mean by
profits we're talking about corporate
profits corporate earnings and things
that will drive you know incremental
decisions you know going back to your
previous discussion about uh you know
whether or not companies are spending
more money on marketing more money on
hiring etc so uh we are not in a
favorable place to be speculating uh on
the long side of most risk assets as a
function of those four uh downturns
um
so i
there's a lot of talk right now about
you know are we in a recession i will
obviously find out when we get this
second quarter gdp print but
what is kind of your thought process
there and like how do you kind of think
about that
yeah so i say you guys are charts are
you able to put them yeah we can pull
the charts up um which one would you
like us to pull up maybe the the first
one so modeling probability yeah let's
pull up the model and model implied
probabilities chart if we can
yeah so this uh this first so what we're
trying to do with these charts is
identify uh whether or not we are in
recession or likely headed to a
recession over the medium term and some
investable time horizon anything over a
year is generally not uh investable from
a risk management perspective it can be
you know it's you can talk about stuff
from year from now but it's not gonna
really matter to markets um so what i'm
showing in this um in this top chart uh
the blue line in the uh upper panel just
shows the new york fed that's the
federal reserve bank of new york's
recession plot implied probability model
uh down at four percent uh four percent
probability of having a recession over
the next 12 months one i think that
number's wrong but two it's uh
significantly lower than where it's
typically at on a mean basis heading
into recession that number's around 27
so typically right into a new you know
recession that number's on average
around 27 so uh tells you a couple
things it tells you one um
at the onset of recession even the
recession probabilities are still
generally low so you need to have four
looking indicators to give you a better
view on that and then number two the red
line in the upper panel just shows the
uh
a model i put together just based on a
couple of bloomberg models that are
anchoring on the tens twos treasury
yield curve and the 10-year three-month
treasury yield curve that per session
probability is currently around 25
historically it's been on average around
35 percent at the onset of recession so
that's much closer to signaling hey look
we might actually be a recession uh but
to me i think the discussion around
recession is really coming from the
consumer um the second chart i send you
is uh consumer confidence yeah we can
pull that up too
yeah absolutely so uh the chart uh the
top upper panel on that chart shows the
blue line just shows uh conference
sports consumer confidence measure
that's sort of uh one of the more
stickier um autocorrelated consumer
confidence measures that we have it
tends to be more correlated to the labor
cycle than the university of michigan
survey which is also why they follow
that tends to be more correlated to
inflation but the key takeaway on this
chart is that historically you've seen
consumer confidence break down below
it's trailing through your average um
you're typically in or just about
heading into recession and very clearly
with the most recent data point we got
yesterday i want to say yesterday or two
days ago um you know 99 i think we're
you know we're now careening well south
of the trailing three year average which
takes me to my final chart um consumer
expectations um you know this uh this
other chart consumer expectations uh
sort of breaks into a couple of
different indices within that consumer
confidence report um again these are
these are uh june data points so they're
pretty relevant to pretty fresh um the
red line in the top panel just shows the
present situation index within that
conference board consumer confidence
report the blue line shows the the
expectations index so how do consumers
think about what's likely to happen over
the you know medium term and as you can
see there's because there's this massive
divergence between how consumers think
the economy is today how they feel about
the economy today relative to where they
think the economy is going to be in the
future that's denoted by the spread
there down at the bottom panel now that
spread and you know minus 80 90 basis
points wide to the negative side is
about as deeply negative as it's ever
been you know it's in the first
percentile on all the monthly uh um
readings since going back to the late
60s when this indicated when these
indicators were born so that tells you
that you know as you can see where those
red bars are in the chart historically
speaking when you get to a very deeply
negative spread between consumers
expectations and how they currently feel
about the economy um you typically are
walking into a recession because that's
typically how it happens right you start
feeling bad about the future
and therefore you adjust your current
spending your current um expenditures et
cetera
to how you feel and this is all part of
the behavioral dynamic associated with
you know economies of financial markets
called prospect theory we don't need to
get into that now definitely go check
out uh danny kahneman's book thinking
fast and slow if you want more details
on that
i like that um and it's like like the
psychology of it um
i i guess like a follow-on to that
because like i'm looking at your models
like
is there a way to like assess um you
know how severe a recession might be
like when you're looking at these in
indicators like how do you kind of think
about like is it like something that's
quick and i would love to
explore that with you
yeah so that's a great question julie so
there's a couple of ways to do that on
an ex-ante basis uh one you could sort
of you know the the the the easiest way
to do that is try to understand kind of
the different leveraged cycle dynamics
the first would be how fast has credit
grown into the downturn uh historically
speaking whenever you see a significant
positive deviation uh in the in the
credit to gdp metric particularly
private non-financial sector credit to
gdp uh into a downturn that's what we
saw in 2007 you typically get a more
deeper nastier kind of asset price led
recession that takes longer to recover
from a second way to explore that on an
ex-anti-basis is looking at the uh
looking just observance you have a
positive deviation a significantly
positive deviation from the trend in
what we call the debt service ratio so
that's the total amount of sort of
interest payments and amortization um or
paying back debt um you know for the
broader private non-financial sector and
currently speaking neither of those two
um indicators are signaling kind of um
calls for significant alarm i.e neither
are suggesting that we're likely to have
a deep lasty prolonged protractor
recession which is a good thing now the
one thing i'll say i'll caveat this by
saying you know the data that you know
we get this uh though we derive those
statistics from are released on a pretty
severe lag so we're talking about q4 21
statistics and it's obviously the end of
the second quarter of 2022 so fast
forward six months from now we could be
getting statistics for the second
quarter of this year that may uh say
otherwise but for now um just being data
driven we can understand that any
recession we are likely to experience
over the next 12 months or so uh should
be shallow should in my opinion i think
it's more likely to resemble the 2001
recession which was you know you got to
need a magnifying glass to you know kind
of really see it on the map it was one
it was the shallowest recession in u.s
economic history at peak to trough
decline and output of minus 70 basis
points but guess what
that didn't matter to the market
s p was cut in half nasdaq was down 80
percent in the span of that uh you know
two and a half year bear market um so
you have to be careful not to associate
your expected outcomes in financial
market terms with your expected outcomes
the economic terms the destination
doesn't have to be the same but the rate
of change is likely to sort of
perpetuate um and feed upon each other